This video is made possible by Shaker and spoon,
Shaker and spoon and send out a cocktail box each month with the ingredients
needed to make bar quality cocktails in your own home.
Yeah,
$20 off your first box by going to Shaker in the spoon.com forward slash.
Biographics.
There's a link below.
Liar does some males.
It on was a much loved revolutionary hero who saved China from the rule of
foreign aggresses.
He multiplies China by bringing the ones as of western industrialized nation to
their shores to others.
Though he is remembered for being a sociopathic Tyron to sacrifice the lives of
millions of people in order to bring his political experiment to life.
In the video today,
the life of the chairman,
a farmer and land owner named Malley Chan was a self made man.
He was born into poverty,
but he worked hard and saved enough to buy two acres of rice patties.
Over the years he employed workers tens the lands for him and most of his
profits went back into expanding his farm.
He builds a comfortable life for his wife when she may and their future
children.
Sadly,
his wife had difficulty getting pregnant and she lost her first two children
during infancy.
She gave birth to her only child mouths and Dong in 1883 growing up,
Mousa Dong lived very comfortable life compared to his peers.
It was not uncommon for Chinese children do walk around without shoes and wear
clothes that were in tatters.
They barely had enough food to eat and they could not afford proper healthcare.
The fact that males are dongs parents could afford to provide all of the basic
necessities for their child is why some people considered them to be wealthy.
The one thing that Mouser Dong had in common with all of the children in China
though was that he was taught the religion and philosophy of Confucianism.
One of his most well known teachings is that everyone should try to go with the
flow means balance,
the energy of ying and Yang.
When it came to the government,
Confucius said that people should try to be satisfied with their lot in life and
they should know their place in order for society to run smoothly.
Confucius says there is governments when the prince is Prince and the minister
is minister.
When the father,
his father,
and the son,
his son,
however males are Dong,
did not agree with everything Confucius taught.
After all,
he knew from firsthand experience that his father was able to work his way out
of poverty.
He wanted to believe that he could grow up to be more than just a farmer's son
in school.
Males that Dorman was one of the top students in his class and he loved reading
as many books as he could get his hands on butts.
At 13 years old,
his parents,
they removed him from his elementary school in order to help his father work on
the farm.
His father tried to arrange a marriage with a young girl named [inaudible] who
was the daughter of a nearby farmer and land owner.
This would have ended his education and completely sealed his fate.
He refused to marry hard at 16 years of age.
He convinced his parents that he wanted to be an intellectual and his parents
agreed to send him to a boarding school and the city of Chang sharp.
When he was in this city,
he met other blank minded people who believed that there was a need to change
the Chinese way of life in the 18 hundreds China,
we're seeing more and more trade from western countries from 1842 1842 Cheyenna
in Great Britain.
They had a big conflict known as the opium wars and it's trying to lost.
After signing the treaty of Nanking,
Hong Kong became a British territory and European traders now had access to
Chinese ports.
Even though this one's a peace treaty,
the Chinese people nicknames this,
the unequal treaties because it appeared as though the Ching Dynasty was bowing
to the demands of Great Britain.
China was far from being an industrialized nation.
That technology was so far behind the rest of the world.
It was far too easy for western countries to take advantage.
In 1895 Japan attempted to overpower China and ran their influence over Korea
and this was known as the first sign Japanese war.
The Cherry on top of an already bad situation came in the year 1908 when the
emperor passed away.
I'm the only male out of the Ching Dynasty was a two year old named per year.
It's not a surprise that people began to lose their faith in the strength of the
dynasty in 1911 and Mouser dawn was 18 years old.
The in high revolution happens and the People's Republic of China broaden ends
to the Ching Dynasty
off the switching to the People's republic.
The overarching government with calls the Kuomintang also known as the
nationalist party or the KMT.
The Kuomintang allowed warlords to rule over their perspective territories
across China.
Each warlord had the power to create their own laws,
charge taxes,
and raise their own armies as a university student mows it on.
His favorite subject was philosophy.
He read the wealth of nations by Adam Smith and the spirits of laws by
Montesquieu.
He also read all of the works of the Chinese revolutionaries who were behind the
People's republic.
During this time,
he created the Association for Students,
self government and said who non fast normal university so that students could
have a voice to protest against the school rules.
He also formed a student volunteer army.
The Greeks had around 80 members and they all shared their ideas on government
and philosophy.
It was during this time that Mouser don was introduced to the work of Karl Marx.
Out of all the political philosophies they studied,
he and his friends agreed with the ideas of communism.
This was because it promised that every person in society would have their basic
needs met now's it don't continue to excel in school and he was number three in
his graduating class.
He got a job at Beijing University as a librarian where he was able to read as
many books as his heart desired.
The Communist Party of China or CCP was established in 1921 one of the founders
lead does how was a librarian at Peking University.
The other was Chen duck sue,
who was an intellectual who had been a part of the People's Republic of China.
After seeing how,
trying to adjust to the new republic docs who believed that the warlords were
taking advantage of the peasant class and that the political system needed
adjusting,
he thought communism would actually be better for that society.
Now's the Dong was just 28 years old at the time and he was one of the many
young people who began attending communist meetings after work.
Once people began to learn about the teachings of Karl Marx,
the Communist Party of China gains a huge following.
Many peasant people were unhappy with their respective warlords and they wanted
a new system of governments.
Of course,
communism was posing a huge threat to the nationalist party and like the rest of
the parties in the republic,
communism actually had the potential to spread across the entire country and
replace them as the leading party.
They believed it was time to get rid of the communists in China before they
gains too much power.
In 1927 and gang working for the KMT attacked and killed members of the
Communist Party,
or they announced the plan to eradicate every single member of the CCP.
This events is remembered as the Shanghai massacre role.
The April the 12th patch over 300,000 communists were killed and 50,000 people
denounced fat party affiliation out of fear.
The Shanghai massacre is credited with starting the Chinese civil war.
Since the KMT was the original party of the Republic of China,
they felt that it was time for them to eliminate the feudal system of warlords
and the communists as well in order to unite all of China under one government.
In 1931 when Mouser Dong was 48 years old,
he was elected as the chairman of the Communist Party.
In 1934 the Chinese civil war was still raging on miles and on led the members
of the Communist Party and what is remembered as the Long March.
They tracked over 4,000 miles through mainland China in their attempts to fend
off KMT forces.
The leader of the Nationalist Party,
Chiang Kai Shek was sending troops after the communists and he ran several
campaigns and his attempts to defeat them mows the dawn did not have an army as
large as the KMT,
but he had his charisma wherever they went.
He used his power of persuasion to tell the villages that communism would
improve their lives.
He promised them that they would never go hungry again.
People are so unhappy living under the rule of their warlords that it wasn't
very hard to convince people to fight for the cause after losing thousands of
men and battles that don would just restock his army with new peasants in the
next village and just keep on marching forward.
In 1937 all of China would have to hit pause on their civil war because Japan
was taking advantage of the chaos by invading Manchuria.
This was known as the second Sino Japanese war.
For years,
Japan was attempted to take over Chinese territories.
The Japanese,
they tortured,
they killed,
they raped Chinese civilians everywhere they went and decimated the Chinese
major cities,
the armies of the warlords in the KMT,
they were already a,
from the losses they sustained while fighting each other.
There was no way they could fend off the Japanese empire on their own.
The leader of the KMT Chiang Kai Shek had to swallow his pride and ask the
Communist Party for help if they're red army was growing in numbers.
They defended China against the Japanese and what is known as the hundred
regiments offensive.
The Red Army was largely made up of peasants who didn't have time for proper
military training,
so mouser on used guerrilla warfare tactics.
They also called in some help of the USSR who closed in on Japanese occupied
Manchuria from the sidewall.
China is on the other.
They succeeded in saving the country.
However,
once the Japanese were gone,
the civil war,
it was back in 1946 miles a dog and his Red Army defeated the Campti and it
became the new rulers of China.
At this point,
people for Mouser Dong was a national hero and the rightful leader of that
country.
Not only did he save them from the Japanese,
but the also unified the country under one rule.
For the first time since the Ching Dynasty,
people were hopeful that things would finally start to change for the better,
but actually they were going to get a whole lot worse.
In 1958 miles are Dong officially began his plan.
This was called the great leap forward.
This was his attempt to use communist ideals to bring modern industrialization
to China.
He might've had the best intentions at heart,
but may matter how many books one may read about creating a new society.
There is a huge difference between theory and actually doing something in real
life.
The greater need forward created a major land reform where citizens,
we're no longer allowed to own private property.
Farmers had to give up their lands to the greater good of the public.
They still have to work,
but they were not allowed to keep the food they were growing because the rules
dictated that people who were far more important to society deserve nourishment
first and that the peasants could be fed with whatever was leftover.
He sent medical services do all Chinese villagers ensuring that all of the
citizens have healthcare and they were fit enough to do manual labor.
He commands it.
Many of the people of China to start constructing factories and new governmental
buildings.
Most peasants weren't farmers their entire lives and they had no idea how to
work in a factory.
Still they,
they were expected to produce steel and other industrialized materials.
There were so many people now working in factories.
It was impossible to properly train or manage everyone despite having a lot of
issues getting adjusted to the new policy of the plan.
It actually worked for a very short window of time.
Crop production went up and people were healthy.
Aaron's had more food to eat than ever before.
Despite the setbacks.
The Chinese people were also able to Iraq,
a few modern buildings.
This progress,
it all came crashing down in less than a year ago.
This happened in the winter of 1959 miles or dawn had suggested that farmers
grow more grain and this was stored in silos.
However,
without grabbing other types of food to store for the winter months,
it men,
the people were to survive only on bread and the winter.
The weather that year,
it was awful as well.
They experienced widespread droughts,
followed by massive typhoons that caused the flooding that destroyed crops,
tigers,
leopards,
and wolves were attacking farmers as they tried to cultivate more lands.
Therefore,
mal created an antipasto campaign where he encouraged people to shoot these
animals on site and eat their meat.
This push tigers and leopards near extinction as people killed 75% of their
population.
The great leap forward with actually a huge step backwards for China and is it
created a widespread famine that killed millions of people.
People resorted to eating household pets like dogs and cats just in order to
survive.
Some even resorted to cannibalism.
In 1959 he was so unpopular that he had to step down as the chairman of the
Communist Party and he handed over his position as state chairman to a more
moderate party representative.
Thee shall Qui,
however,
mows it on,
continued to work in a leading position in the governments and tried to run his
great leap forward from behind the scenes.
Instead of recognizing that his policy was doomed to fail mouser dawn was
convinced that this was just bad luck and it's press the people to keep going.
However,
people just continued to die year after year.
Finally,
in 1961 the great leap forward,
it was canceled by the time he finally ended the policy.
36 million people that died.
Yeah.
You'd think that after being responsible for the deaths of millions of people
and somehow not being killed for it,
the had no,
it was time to quit,
but in 1966 miles of dawn trying to regain the trust of the people and become
state chairman,
once again,
he has a place,
the blame for his mistakes somewhere else.
He claims that the Bosch was he the top 1% of society were ruining everything
and that Mao himself,
he was on the side of the peasants.
He builds up a cult of personality and people,
they strongly supported them again because well,
they remembered him as a revolutionary hero who saved their country from the
Japanese and provided them with food rations and free healthcare is fully was.
They were willing to do whatever you asked.
He knew from his days as a college student that young people were perfect for
molding into revolutionaries.
He convinced a group of students called the Red God to seek out anyone who was
speaking out against the Communist Party.
He encouraged them to even murder their professors who spoke against Mao's
policies just in order to make an example of them.
According to some accounts smells,
red guards swept so savage,
they partook in flesh and banquets or ritualistic cannibalism if their enemies
mouser dorm called the USSR and North Korea treater revisionist.
See what bastardizing the original work of Karl Marx.
His interpretation of communism was so different from the rest of the world that
many people call his philosophy Maoism instead of isolating is people from the
outside world like other communist nations.
He encouraged globalization,
open trade,
which is why China's economy eventually rebounded and did need this actually set
the stage for the economic strength that China has today.
In 1968 the minister of Pakistan brought a gift of 14 mangoes to chairman.
Now,
people of China had never eaten tropical fruit before,
so this was a delicacy to them.
Now could impossibly 40 mangoes on his own,
so he hands down with the fruit twist political team and a couple got in the
hands of a group of factory workers.
They were so mesmerized by this magical sweet fruit that they literally started
to wash a bit saying that it was a symbol of the wonderful new things that
Chairman Mao would bring to their land.
They taste it in a glass case and when the freeway went bad,
they replaced it with a wax replica.
One man who had never tried mango before questioned why everyone was worshiping
this piece of fruit.
He tried to compare it to a sweet potato.
You simply couldn't believe that mangoes could taste so great.
Well then it got a little bit ridiculous because even the mere suggestion that a
mango wasn't a magical fruit was enough to kill a man for treason.
This is just one of many examples of how irrationally devoted to Mouser Dong.
People were in the,
in 1970 when the country was running low on building supplies,
Mouser don audit his workers to tear down the Great Wall of China in order to
use the bricks to build new houses and the damned you also destroyed engine dot
worker or anything else that was considered to be a symbol of the bourgeoisie.
He was willing to dismantle thousands of years of Chinese history and culture in
order to execute is communist vision.
When he was getting older and Mouser don was shameless when it came to you
reaping the benefits of being a communist dictator.
You almost never bathed or brushed his teeth and claims that he fenced himself
inside the bodies of his mistresses and not surprisingly,
he contracted sexually transmitted infections and spread them deep.
Several women who actually wore their illness as something of a badge of honor
since it was given to them by Chairman Mao.
Yup.
When he was in his sixties he appointed a 16 year old girl named Jan Yufeng to
be his personal secretary.
She spent so much time with him that even Mao Zedong's wife had to go through
January thing first before she could make an appointment and speak with her
husband.
In 1973 he was sitting in a trade meeting with Henry Kissinger and he reportedly
offered to trade 10 million Chinese women to the United States.
He said that women caused too many problems and that it would be better to just
get rid of them.
In 1974 his third wife,
the beautiful actress Jane Chin,
decided that she would not sit around waiting for husbands,
respect and affection.
She began gathering our own collection of young male lovers.
She got so bold she wouldn't even allow her boyfriend's do show up at the house
and now never protested against our fas.
When he died in 1976 people,
they were devastated him.
He was buried in a crystal caskets so that people could see his body when they
came to visit lines of people queued up to pay their respects,
and many of them openly,
when they saw the body of their dear leader,
even to this day,
the memory of males are Dong is revered by many as they remember him.
That's one of the great heroes of the nation,
but loving more hasten China would be a very different place today if it was not
for malice.
Saddam maybe without him trying to,
would have never become a leading economic power house,
but maybe without seven millions of people would not have died is the chairman
now,
not exactly the cheeriest of subjects,
but you know what,
can take the edge off his communist ways?
Well,
a cocktail,
and that's convenient because today's video is brought to you by Shaker and
spirit.
Now,
no,
I'm not going to mix up some cocktails at work because I'm not don draper.
So let's through the magic of television and travel home.
Hello,
welcome to my home.
Let's make some cocktails.
Good.
So we have Shaker and spoon.
You get three cocktails that you get to have a crack at this month.
They are the spice of life tea and honey and the mighty creek cobbler.
Now I believe that gets them,
so we used one of these hydrated mandarin wheels,
so I'm going to make this,
it's mostly with Irish whiskey and a half a bottle of Irish whiskey on hand,
so that's a good thing.
First step,
I need to crush some ice.
Okay.
Now with Shaker and spoon,
it's available in the u s obviously I'm not there,
so they make special accommodations and send me this stuff internationally,
which I really appreciate.
They normally ship the fruit with them I to by my own orange,
but don't worry everything you need except for the booze comes in the box.
I also worry this orange is absolutely massive and might not actually fit in my
gloss.
Okay.
This is a fine looking orange.
Good news or my needs it bit them in the glass.
I should read the recipe I suppose before I start with these things,
but the two big,
even when my shaker,
this is a ridiculously huge orange.
I'm just going to cut them in half and put them in like that because apparently
my local shop sells mucins oranges,
one and a half ounces of orange spice syrup.
This is it.
Go Myself.
One of these.
I always feel like it was such a bartender we like and it makes that,
that nice ringing sound,
so put that in there.
Pop that in there.
Good.
A muddle of that.
Six seconds.
You know what's cool?
If you don't know what modeling is,
it tells you right here using a muddler press fruit or herbs into the bottom of
the glass,
usually with added sugar or syrup.
When muddling.
Be careful not to destroy the fruit or herbs you want to release their island
flavor.
Not Pulverize.
I didn't have a muddler.
I'm pretty sure they sent me a muddler.
I think I lost it.
I'm sorry.
Today we're using some Tullamore dew.
That in there.
Add that all in math.
Oh yeah.
Oh.
Dawnish we want on these bad boys.
Oh my God.
It is super good.
Thank you.
Shaker and spearing.
I'm sure you can all understand why this.
Probably one of my favorite sponsorships.
You know,
lots of useful stuff,
but this is the fun stuff.
You get $20 off your first box with Shaker and spoon at sea on a link in the
description below to do that.
As always,
thank you for watching.
Thanks for Shaker in the spoon.
Back to the studio that is Shaker and spirit and you can get $20 off your first
box.
They are going to Shaker [inaudible] dot com slash biographics thanks.
Do you shake current and speaking for the sponsorship and thanks to you for
watching.